Now moving on to the last part of this.
Quite a few people vibecoded this con
and are still creating things on the fly
and have announcements. So I would like
to start with Rob Lee who has done some
pretty cool work for us making us more
of an online AI powered AI native
conference or whatever. So let's start
with that and then we'll go to Dan
Hubard and then to Glen Thorp.
All right, I think you got to eat. Love
the questions.
All right, let me get plugged in here.
My name is Rob Lee.
I'm with the SANS Institute
and I'm going to get the video kicked
off and I'll start.
So starting off with the question going
back to what Gotti just said, I
developed the SIFT workstation 18 years
ago and in working with AI as little as
possible and trying to learn as much as
possible over the past 2 to 3 years, it
occurred to me about 3 months ago, why
haven't I not installed cloud code on
top of the SIFT workstation, did about
45 minutes to an hour worth of work
configuring the cloud MD file and
skills.
And I essentially went into cloud code
and I said here's a hard drive find
evil.
This is the command essentially you type
into cloud code once this is configured
on top of the inst response toolkit that
we developed and it of course kicks off
starts cranking through. Now, this is
like 16x speed because what you're about
to see is a 14minute processing time
that basically at the end of this, which
typically takes an instant responder,
and I asked yesterday as a poll, about 3
days to get from initial C drive of an
intrusion into a full report. And I'm
going to put all these resources online
in the general chat so everyone could
download them, get access to the report,
get access to the sift workstation, even
the notebook LM I have set up so you
could ask basic questions. How do I
start? So 14 minutes later, I'm going to
go ahead and skip to the end of this
just so everyone could see that it
definitely took 14 minutes. 14 minutes
27 seconds. Think about this for one
second. And I'm going to go in 2x on the
report. This is the report it
automatically generated with no other
input and comments.
Go ahead and click go.
Nailing the full intrusion analysis of a
single system in a compromise. Now the
reason we need to accelerate to the
speed, it does not mean we remove the
human investigator from the intrusion
analysis. All the artifacts that are in
here require that baseline knowledge.
But with offensive teams out there able
to accelerate from things that took
months down to days or minutes, it is
now essential that we're able to meet
that speed with intrusion analysis.
Thank you.
>> So, as mentioned, was not prepared for
this at all, but it's fun to wake up to
a surprise message for
>> Oh, I'm Glenn Thorp uh with great noise.
Um, yeah. So, woke up, opened Slack, saw
a message from God saying, "Hey, you
want to just jump on stage for a few
minutes and show a thing that you made."
So, that's cool. Um, it's not really a
great story except for the side quest
that it created. Uh, Sunday night I was
getting ready for the conference and
kind of like, uh, they shared a G sheet.
I'm OCD. I wanted like a personalized
agenda. So went to cloud code as we all
do and vibe coded what's a pretty cool
interface like your talks right you can
take some notes uh gives you a a
customized agenda you can export it
share it whatever so that's not really
the fun part though because I think we
can all do that here by now what was
funny is I made it I was really excited
about it I shared it with my boss and I
was all proud and then I started Ed
looking at it after I had posted it
online and the LLM had confused some of
the talks and so it caught my surprise
when I saw that there was a talk with
another uh speaker here and the very end
of the talk said and we will display or
show how we integrated this into great
noise intelligence.
That was news and I was actually pretty
interested with it but I was like I
don't think that's right. So went back
to the actual Google sheet. Obviously it
was wrong. I was like, "Oh man." So went
through, got the, you know, just
basically reverified it and shared it
and gave it more explicit instructions
as we've learned this week to verify,
validate, whatever, share. Um, so then
it corrected it. So if you look in the
PR for this, it's pretty funny. Also,
Wi-Fi is not
uh being super
speedy. Anyway, so in the end, 25% of
the talk descriptions were correct, 75%
were wrong. So it's kind of a funny
story for a bcoded AI uh thing, but it
worked out in the end. And uh you'll see
on our talk later, the irony will come
when we talk about what we're presenting
and how my focus of that project was on
the validation skill. So you know, a
little humbling, but it's pretty cool.
All right. So, yesterday um I was trying
to find kind of all the comments on
social media um from the conference and
uh which is not super easy to do across
all the platforms. Is this coming up
yet? [clears throat]
There we go. Um
and uh
and we'll make this a little simpler.
Um,
and uh, so
because it was hard to find, why can't I
scroll down? Um, I just vibe coded up a
little thing that scrolls all the
comments from all the major social media
networks. Um, and you can actually go
and give kudos to the presenters and add
comments. Um, but the the real kind of I
guess more fascinating thing from a
security perspective is I looked up the
the actual amount of code that it
created. This took like 8 minutes and it
was 6,800 lines of code that was created
in 8 minutes to do this. Um, and uh, I
think there was uh, something like 17
different dependencies
um, that were part of it. Um, but
because this is a security conference, I
also thought, well, wow, what if Oh, by
the way, this crawled the website and
mimicked the exact website is
unprompted. As you can see, it looks a
lot like it. Um, but I thought, well,
wouldn't it be fun to actually see how
many people actually registered for next
year's event?
Um, so you actually can go on um and uh
add your password, your credit card, and
your details for next year's, which is
$7.99. Um, not not uh 179 if you're
interested. Um, so you can think about
how easy it is to do this across your
favorite other site on the internet and
make this happen. Um, so that's the
demo. It was made with lovable. I'll put
the prompt in the uh in the chat notes.
And the good thing about lovable is at
the very bottom right you can actually
um edit somebody else's lovable and fork
and create your own really easily if you
want to do that. So thank you.
>> My name is Seapik.
So I wanted to say first of all thank
you to Gaddy and thank you to all of you
for being such an incredible community.
And you know I think we have to realize
that we are all you are all very special
because you have some insights which
most of the people out there don't have
yet. And the question is just how do we
communicate this in a proper way because
that's the only thing on how we can make
make uh you know bring a positive world
into um um into the world out there. And
the same you know as some of you tried
tried out already playing with a lot of
offensive tools. I've I've did the same
a couple of uh weeks ago. Just built a
small all day lab and literally I've not
touched uh you know father any tools for
the last 8 10 years and I was able to
find a lot of very interesting stuff and
some of this is already validated. So my
question was how do we really build
build this as a um you know as a
communication platform? How can we
transfer this um this uh this message on
what's happening out there? And the
first thing I did is just to go back and
look back on what kind of research was
happening in the past around
vulnerability disclosure around
vulnerability exploitation and so on and
just looking back obviously at the
foundational problem cyber security
being an econ economics problem looking
back at some of the research around
patchiff for instance right so what's
going to happen if machines are going to
be able to reconstruct patches and build
exploits automatically uh within a
couple of minutes and not hours or case.
My question was how do we visualize this
and how do we transport as well the call
to action um on how we can you know do
something against that going forward. So
this is a small project which was um
vibe coded pretty much over the weekend
as well including some um selection of
call to actions on what we can do and um
you know visualization of one single
metric and the metric is time to
exploitation.
You want to see it?
All right.
So
[snorts]
there we go.
What's happening with Wi-Fi?
>> We're all talking about AI, but Wi-Fi
doesn't work.
All right. Um, I can I can talk through
that. So
what I did is I just have agents to go
out and research all the different
trusted data sources like uh CISA like
uh some commercial data sources
vulnerability check um NVD collect all
the information together and try to
understand how we can measure time to
exploitation and Safari was faster. Oh
my god, look at that.
And and this is the result what we've
got from that. So just looking back at
the data in 2020, the time to
exploitation was more than a year.
Just last year we've crossed months and
now it's just about a day.
So
how did it change our patching
processes? How quickly are we patching
today?
It's still not change like everybody
who's working in a big company there's
still a lot of challenges around how you
can patch. We're not going to change
this in a foundational way. And now just
looking at the number of um looking at
the number of zero days on this
weaponized exploits you see that more
more than half of them started to be
already zero days. So they either
exploited before patches being released
um or the same day. Now what can happen
without creating too much foot but
looking at all the CES out there we see
that the rate of the weaponized exploits
is pretty constant around 2%.
So if finding exploit building exploits
finding CVE is going to be as cheap as
we believe this is going to be
dramatically um dangerous for the world
and for all of us. So what um yeah what
I'd like to actually all of you to to do
is if you're looking for one single
slide to transfer this to to communicate
this to your board to your Caesars this
is what you can use. I'm very glad that
a lot of people here are supporting this
we've got Phil we've got Bruce Schneia
we've got Heather uh if you want to
leave a comment please go on the website
and leave a comment around this. Thank
you very much.